as deep endemic rips through the world
shattering national health systems and
economies a global response to help pick
up the pieces has never been more
essential but International Cooperation
has sagged under the weight of the
coronavirus the United Nations the World
Health Organization and the g20 all
unable to take the lead countries have
closed themselves off each locked ante
contest to secure supplies of limited
resources like face masks protective
clothing and medication but how it is
now is not how it has to be depend emic
remains a chance for countries to come
together and create opportunity from
crisis so will they
how will the world look after all this
welcome to Kofi 19 specially here on DW
news I'm Chris Coburn Berlin it is good
to have you with us now when looking at
the what the future might bring
is good to remember what Shakespeare
once said past is prologue meaning
looking back can help one look ahead not
the Dutch historian Rutger Breck man has
made a career looking at the great
crises of the past millennia he's
concluded that they've always led to
major interventions and eventually
beneficial shifts for him the
coronavirus calamity has shown the kind
of solidarity that humanity is capable
of heralding positive changes for
greater society so let's bring in the
man himself historian Rick Bregman it's
good to have you on the program in your
new book human kind a hopeful history
you say that empathy compassion and
kindness make us human beings now how do
people hoarding toilet paper buying more
loads of noodles and spreading fake news
during the current crisis fit into that
argument that's a great question you
know this is all theory within Western
culture and science it's called a veneer
theory it's the idea that civilization
is only a thin veneer and that as soon
as something happens say a natural
disaster to nah
or an earthquake or a pandemic that
people go back to their true selves and
that they show they really are that
they're basically selfish right animals
beasts so they start hoarding stuff and
they panic etc etc this is a very
popular story in the media you see it
always after natural disasters you know
think about Katrina 2005 well it's what
people have been examining - originally
it's what people are having severe it's
the opposite actually
I think it's pretty much the opposite so
if he zoom out a little bit I think the
vast majority of the behavior that we
see right now is pro-social in nature
you see you really see an explosion of
cooperation and kindness on the local
level and sure there is some panic by
there is some hoarding but even there I
mean I'd love to talk about toilet paper
by the way because the fascinating thing
is that most of the toilet paper
shortages was just a supply delivery
problem right so there are two kinds of
toilet paper commercial toilet paper and
the toilet paper that you use at home
right so the kind of circuit paper they
use that an office is different from
what you use it at home and suddenly
there's this huge increasing demand of
you know the toilet paper that you use
at home because people are an element so
they go to the toilet at home so hope
easily I mean that's the reason why
there was suddenly such a shortage but
what we tend to do because this is such
an old idea within our culture is to say
oh that must be because of selfishness
in hoarding and sure there's a little
bit of that but I think to zoom-out and
if you look at the science we have on
this you find that actually most
behavior is pro-social in nature and
people are actually helping each other
so what specific signs of a change for
the better
do you see okay so what we have seen in
the past 15 to 20 years is that there
has been a kind of silent revolution
within different scientific disciplines
so whether we talk about anthropology or
archeology or psychology or sociology
all these scientists that move to a more
hopeful view of human nature and the
fascinating thing is that they often
don't even know it from each other so
for example biologists have been arguing
in the past couple of years that we have
evolved to be friendly
they literally call this survival of the
frame
which means that for millennia when we
were nomads nomadic hunter-gatherers I
was actually the friendliest among us
who had the most kids so the biggest
chance of passing on their genes moons
in the next generation but psychologists
have been discovered something very
similar you know for example they study
the behavior people during an emergency
say someone's drowning or a text in the
streets and based on real evidence from
CCTV footage they find that in 90% of
all cases people actually help each
other so it's very much the opposite of
what saved the news of our culture or
the Hollywood movies always tell you ok
Rutger you're also claimed that the era
of neoliberalism has come to an end
thanks to the coronavirus why well I
don't know have you seen the editorial
in the Financial Times
you know from two weeks ago I mean this
is the biggest maybe one of the most
powerful newspapers in the globe and
even the Financial Times is saying right
now in an editorial that there needs to
be an end to the policy direction of the
last 40 years and for 40 years we've
relied on values like individualism
selfishness and you know the central
idea of you know what most people call
the neoliberal era is the idea that most
people are selfish and during the midst
of in the midst of a pandemic you
realise but that's not gonna get you
anywhere and what has been happening is
that ideas that just five six years ago
were seen as crazy and very unrealistic
are now moving into the mainstream you
know the idea of wealth Texas basic
income you know a bigger rule for the
state all these ideas are becoming much
more prominent right now hmm Rutger
Bregman historian and we certainly hope
that you're making the case for a better
society after the pandemic does come to
Rutger thank you so much for talking to
us
sure thanks well from picturing what the
world will look like after the pandemic
on to the issues of the here and now the
questions you've been sending us about
the corona virus and there are so many
our science editor Derek Williams hardly
gets to leave his home office
if you've had covert 19 and recovered do
you still need to wear a mask
although the effectiveness of wearing a
mask as a measure to prevent you from
catching covet 19 is still being debated
there's now a pretty broad consensus
that it certainly makes sense to wear
one if you have the disease because it
will make you less of a danger for
others in theory if you had the virus
and recovered
you shouldn't have to wear a mask for at
least a while because theory says that
after fighting off the disease you
should be immune which means you can no
longer produce the virus and infect
others or on the flipside you cannot be
reinfected by others the problem is that
this is all still very much theory as
experts still have too little
information about things like the
possibility of reinfection they can't
yet make real science-based
recommendations about people who have
recovered they need more time to gather
data so if you want to continue to wear
a mask even after having kovat 19 I
don't think anyone at this point would
consider that silly when we have a
vaccine with people who have already had
clover 19 be vaccinated as well this is
an interesting question because it
touches closely on the question of
immunity to Cove in 19 which we still
don't know much about but by the time a
vaccine becomes available which despite
a lot of hype nobody expects to happen
before next year we will have a lot more
information about how long your immune
response is likely to last when you've
had this disease that will of course
inform decisions about who needs
vaccinations most what's clear is that
if and when they become available
frontline health workers will be the
first to be vaccinated
and I imagine that'll include those who
have already had the virus even if
they're only given it as a precautionary
measure depending on what we know by
then about the length of the average
immune response it's quite likely I
think that people who haven't had the
disease will be prioritized over those
who have had it but this is all still
really hypothetical because we still
don't have the data we need on a large
number of critical aspects and any
potential vaccines are still quite a way
down the road can diet affect how
vulnerable you are to covert 19 probably
no other factor has more of an impact on
your health in the long term then your
diet does I haven't seen any specific
scientific studies showing that a
particular diet like a plant-based one
makes you less vulnerable to COBIT 19
than any other diet that would probably
be impossible to show anyway in the
middle of this pandemic but there are
recommendations that health bodies and
doctors are continuing to make pretty
much across the board first and foremost
even though they might not be easy to
come by where you live you should try to
eat a range of fresh unprocessed foods
every day second drink plenty of water
and of course no matter how great the
temptation try to avoid comfort foods
loaded with sugar and fat and salt
they might lift your mood temporarily
but in the long run they won't give your
immune system what it needs to put up a
fight